they came presumably in search of
brighter beginnings but this is where so
many lives reach such a brutal end the
bodies of 46 suspected migrants found
inside this lorry in a remote part of
san antonio we are dealing with a
horrific human tragedy
so i would urge you all to think
compassionately and pray for the
deceased
the ailing
the families
and
we hope that those responsible
for
putting these people in such humane
conditions are prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
the dozens inside had entered the
country illegally those who survived
were taken to hospitals suffering from
heat stroke temperatures in this part of
texas on monday were nudging 40 degrees
celsius
the patients that we saw were hot to the
touch
they were suffering
from heat stroke heat exhaustion
no signs of water in the vehicle it was
a refrigerated tractor trailer
but there was no
visible working ac unit on that rig
border officials were already on high
alert amid record levels of migrant
crossings from mexico the tragedy
already been politicized texas governor
greg abbott tweeting these deaths are on
biden they're a result of his deadly
open border policies they show the
deadly consequences of his refusal to
enforce the law
this is it appears one of the worst
instances of migrant death in the u.s in
recent years an astonishing loss in
horrific circumstances martha kellner
sky news